it's that time of year again and I've
been getting a lot of questions from you
twelve have been just trying to work out
what should I do next year when I leave
school how do I choose what my career
path should be how do I work that out
how do I go about making that kind of
decision and it's been ten years since I
made that decision and I've learned a
lot of things in that time a lot of
things which if I'd known back then
definitely I'm not sure if I would have
made very different choices but I would
have understood a lot more about what I
was doing and had a lot more confidence
so here in no particular order six
things that I think you should think
about as you choose career number one
play to your strengths and your loves
and maybe that's a bit obvious to you do
something which you're good at and do
something which you enjoy that's
probably one of the most oft-repeated
kinds of principles you should keep in
mind when you're making this kind of
decision but what do i mean by that it's
for plenty of strengths so when you
think about okay what am I good at and
what what energizes me think about are
you a people person or do you prefer to
work and kind of like a more solitary
environment where you can do things on
your own
are you a creative type you a leader are
you highly analytical or do you like
reading what things are you good at and
really importantly ask people who know
you really well what you're good at
because number one you might think
you're good at things which you are not
good at your friends or your family
those people who've known you a long
time they'll be able to tell you whether
that's true or not and secondly there
are probably some things you're good at
that you have no idea you're good at you
never really think of them as your
strengths and when you ask others for
their honest opinion people who've known
you over a long period of time they
might be able to reveal things about you
that you're good at which you weren't
aware of before and then not only plenty
of strengths but play to your loves so
what kinds of things do you enjoy what
what are you passionate about what
drives you think about those things so
that when you go about work one of the
most common questions I get is well how
do you stay motivated work is really
hard whatever work you do even the ones
that look
clamorous will look really easy there
very hard work
so what's going to keep you going during
those time so the late nights or the
long days it's going to be the fact that
you have a real desire to do what you're
doing and it's a really sad position to
be in to get into a job into a career
and to actually have the daily practices
and activities of your job drive you
nuts and frustrate you that's not a
place you want to be so number one
plenty of strengths and your loves as
well secondly don't confuse the degree
with the job what I mean by that when
you get a unique right you might have
spent three or four or five years
studying at university or TAFE or
wherever you go and a lot of people make
their decision about what they should do
on the basis of what's the degree like
what are the hours like where where will
I have to travel to my doctor go
interstate or is the University of in
faraway but really that's of very minor
importance when you compare it to the
actual job you're gonna do after you
leave uni like it's you know roughly
four years of study maybe a bit more
versus say forty years in your job if
you live that long
right so that's a really easy comparison
to make you've got to work out whether
you're gonna really enjoy the job itself
and sometimes the degree and the job are
drastically different I'll just give you
a common example my friends who are in
finance right now and they studied
Commerce or may become more good
communist on its own just a straight
commerce it's one of the shortest
degrees there is three years and the
contact hours are relatively small like
less than fifteen hours a week and so
you get this impression that ah it's a
pretty easy kind of degree to study but
when you get out into the workforce
people in finance jobs are among the
hardest-working that I know of the hours
are crazy it's not uncommon for new
grads and even you know after you've
graduated for a while and you've been in
your job for a few years to work crazy
hours like 8:00 a.m. to 8:00 p.m. for
months on end so don't confuse the
degree and whether it's easy or hard or
it's like with the actual job which is
what you're really going to stick with
how do you make sure you keep them too
steeped well when you're asking people
for advice you know should I do this
should I do that
what do you think about it now that
you've gone through it ask people that
you need that's fine but don't just ask
people who have only studied it and
haven't actually worked in the job try
and find some people with some
experience ask your parents or your
parents friends or if you've got other
older people that you know try and find
someone with five or ten years in the
job and they'll be able to tell you what
the job is really like and you won't get
a better sense of whether you'll be good
at it or whether you'll enjoy it or not
okay thirdly be willing to take some
risks now this is something that a lot
of people who are going to watching this
video are very averse to I'm a
risk-averse kind of person I don't like
going to places where it's uncertain or
I'm not sure how things are gonna play
out I really like to have certainty
about how something's gonna plan out
what what steps I have to go through and
what the outcome will be but when it
comes to career you've got to be willing
to take some risks
here's some examples if it's really what
drives you and you're really good then
consider taking an uncommon course you
know a lot of your friends will probably
do similar kinds of degrees and maybe
you know as was in my case there was no
one in my grade at school who chose the
course and the career that I chose in
fact there wasn't even someone that
you're above me or the you below me for
a while so that that was a risk that I
took that I wouldn't have any friends at
the in the course that I did and even
when I went to the same university as my
friends I often didn't get to see them
because the university is a huge place
they were like 30,000 students at the
university I went to so that was a risk
but it was it was totally worth it
other risks you might take are making a
choice but be really to change after say
six months or 12 or a couple of years
when you work out on this is what I want
after all this is not gonna be helpful
it's a risk you know and you feel like
you've wasted a couple of years but it's
better to decide after two years that
you
should change rather than say after 20
years be stuck in something which you
which really drives you crazy and you
don't enjoy and isn't helpful to people
if you're in that kind of position
you're not going to be doing a good job
and you're not going to be helpful to
the people who you're actually serving
in your job so be willing to take risks
like that in choosing your career okay
fourthly and related to the last one
don't expect your career to be perfect
okay when I said you should be willing
to take risks and change courses or
change careers and jobs after you get
there that doesn't mean you should get
into a university degree and it's like
ah this isn't exactly what I dreamed of
it's not it's not just right I'm just
gonna leave it straight away
my generation Gen Y has become kind of
famous for not being able to hold down a
job or or floating between different
careers and changing and I think part of
that is because my generation often has
unrealistic expectations of what their
job will be and they kind of had this
idea that once they pick the right thing
they'll kind of sort of float on clouds
after they've picked it and it'll be
really awesome everything will be easy
but that's usually not the case even if
you've made the right choice things will
not be easy you know for instance every
job has parts that people don't like to
do even though the best jobs you know so
for instance one of the things that I'm
thinking of my friends are around my age
who are doing medicine which so many
people aspire to it's got parts of the
job that suck you know they're not to
mention the fact that there's so many
years of study but after you get into
hospitals you have to do things like
shift work and your your life just gets
turned upside down for weeks at a time
and the pay isn't this great at
different stages and it can be really
difficult to have relationships and
start family and all that kind of things
so every job is positive so as a as a
teacher I don't enjoy writing exams or
writing reports I'd much rather just be
in the classroom explaining things and
helping people learn that's what drives
me but they kind of putt and pass will
they come together so every part every
job is gonna have bits in it that you
don't like okay but you know you're also
kind of tested to be perfect in that
things won't be good right away and you
might have to make long-term sacrifices
and I'm thinking of people like say if
you want to be a business owner you
might spend years making what was their
income and having to work really really
long nights until you you know make it
big or you get into you're able to start
a business at the place where it's gonna
be most effective it might take years
decades to get to that point and then
you'll really enjoy it or things like
again for myself my career just isn't a
very high income Korea even though it's
what I love I don't get paid a lot you
know relatively speaking for it and I
didn't think that that would be that big
a deal I didn't picture myself in high
school was one of those people who
absolutely loves money and wants to have
you know massive salaries but I have to
say when I first in my first few years
when I was working and I'd see my
friends graduate people who say went to
Investment Banking and I B's you know
they might make in their first year if
they like land the right job and their
skills are recognized they might be
making six figures annually just very
quickly after graduating and I have to
admit that's done a little bit so are
you willing to sort of make those
long-term sacrifices again if you're
going to go into like a creative pursuit
maybe if we go into fashion a
photography or design or anything like
that often people in those jobs are
going to be doing grueling video sort of
low class work for a long time before
they they hit the level that we're
really that they're really pleased with
working with so be ready for it to not
be perfect and also you know Defra get
that often we only love things after
we're good at things right and I often
get that you know I teach math right so
people often say to me after being in my
class for a few months like I hated math
before but now that I get it
it's actually not that bad I quite enjoy
it right so can you picture that you may
get into
and be not very skilled at it have very
low competency if think is not that good
but then once you actually start to
develop skill you're like wow I love
this this is great I love coming to work
so you gotta be patient with it be
willing to take risk it's like I said it
change when it's the right thing to do
but don't just this sucks I'm out of
here
other than gonna you know it's been two
weeks and my job isn't you know really
awesome you've got to give it a little
more time on that okay so don't expect
things to be perfect fifthly you got to
get this in your head and it's gonna be
really hard to think about it and and
believe it but your job whatever you
choose your career it's not about you
you know all the criteria that we talked
about so far there have been about what
you love and what you're good at and
what fits you but really every
worthwhile job is about creating a
product or rendering a service that
benefits other people and so don't just
think about oh what's going to be
fulfilling for me that tends to be the
way that our society in our culture
encourages people to just pick what's
good for you but you should also pick a
job which is good for your community
which contributes to the people around
you benefits Society and you know it's
not just you don't have to be altruistic
just to make a decision like that
even if you just have just want to be
sort of yeah it's about me it's actually
one of the most self frustrating things
to have a job and it just be about you
it is not satisfying at all in the long
term to do a job and at the end the only
person who benefits is just yourself
okay we are built to be part of
community and to have a job which
actually contributes to other people and
is good for them so don't just think
about what's going to be fulfilling for
you think about when I pick a career I'm
gonna do it because our our country or
other countries needs people who are
skilled and excellent at this particular
kind of job lastly remember the
privilege of choice it's kind of a funny
thing to have this conversation about
choosing Korea and that's such a big
burden for us in this age because you
know in decades past a lot of the people
who are watching this
we'll have been bought in this country
but their parents were migrants they
came to this country because they
dreamed of having choices and
flexibility that we kind of have now and
take for granted and in fact you know
they would have given anything to have
the kind of ability to choose between
careers and have a great education and
have all these paths laid out in front
of them and in many cases they did give
everything you know I can speak from my
own parents point of view they came to
this country and my mom was a newsreader
for television station back where she
came from
it's very highly acclaimed and she came
to this country and she was a
stay-at-home mom so that me and my
siblings could have the opportunity to
have a world-class education and then be
able to on the basis of that school in
University choose what we want to do
with our lives and so as you try and
toss out one of my preferences gonna be
what should I do with the rest of my
life don't think about it just in terms
of what a tough decision it will be even
though it is tricky to choose just
remember it's a bit like the picture
that I have in my head is of us sort of
walking into a banquet and there's all
this amazing food laid out and we have
this problem problem of having to pick
what should I eat right well for many of
us all the choices laid out in front of
us are fantastic choices so don't get
caught up in oh man this is terrible I
have to eat caviar or you know prawns or
whatever wonderful food is there
remember it's a privilege to be able to
choose and all the different kinds of
choices that you have are in many ways
or any fantastic choices
so in summary do what you love and what
you're good at
don't confuse the degree with the job
you're going to do with the degree be
willing to take some risks don't expect
it to be perfect right away remember
your job is not really about you and
lastly realise the privilege of the
choice that you have to make good luck